es absolutamente Claro que la visita del
Rey Carlos a Alemania está cargada de
simbolismo Y eso quedó en evidencia
Desde los primeros minutos después de su
llegada a Berlín donde fue recibido con
honores militares en uno de los
principales símbolos de la capital de
Alemania la puerta de brandeburgo fue
una recepción Por cierto extremadamente
inusual para Alemania pues las
recepciones de este tipo se realizan
normalmente en el Palacio presidencial
Pero también es claro que el Rey Carlos
quiere que su visita a Alemania vaya
mucho más allá de ese simbolismo vaya
mucho más allá de enfatizar las
relaciones entre Reino Unido y Alemania
también quiere que esa visita tenga un
claro componente político enfocado en
particular en temas como la lucha contra
el cambio climático la sostenibilidad y
la energía verde son tres temas que
están presentes en la agenda de la
visita del Rey Carlos una visita de tres
días en la que no solamente estará
visitando Berlín y sus alrededores sino
en la que también viajará en tren a
Hamburgo en el norte del país